there are the best part of a thousand
favelas in Rio vast sprawling slaughters
many controlled by drug gangs some of
the favelas are worse than others but
all are violent here police raids and
gang battles are common but it's a scale
of the violence that beggars belief
you have to remind yourself that this
isn't actually a war zone stuck in the
middle is a war a school in Mary it's
surrounded by narrow alleyways where the
fighting often takes place
[Music]
this is the audio of the latest
firefight teachers recorded the shooting
while they try to comfort the terrified
children
and is this factions fighting each other
or salute
Yvonne D'Mello is the head she's been
here for 20 years
okay so that's like a war that's the war
yeah last year was 159 days this year
she's already 45 days it's incredible no
it's incredible is amazing amazing
believe me I've been in Mosel and it's
not as much as that this is old a this
is only 2 minutes and 15 that we record
but to go over all days nobody even has
to split her time at work half is
teaching half is counseling the effect
of the children start with the children
is they get paralyzer to know many lose
the voice they could not talk the eyes
gaze it they're not not possible to look
at you
orders get the so scared that they have
convulsions others get aggressive or
this cry is today i have with the cisco
has 280 students i have health of the
school traumatize you have to go up to
them it's difficult to illustrate what a
no-go zone this really is they check the
alleyway for gang members then ushered
me into a neighboring home on the roof
is a sign it says school don't shoot
that's for the police helicopters there
in danger from everyone
they actually had to clear the street
make sure it was safe for us to actually
go in and the school is what 15 feet
away and they still had to make sure
that the alleyway was clear because the
and the armed gunman we've seen them are
on the other side of that wall and the
other side of this and they're in
different factions and that's why the
school find herself right in the middle
of a turf war every single day so you'll
basically safe within your area the
teachers barely leave the school keeping
within a few meters the government's
violent crackdown on crime gangs hasn't
according to the Vaughn made life any
better rather it's worse she says she
like many here a critical of what is
happening I don't think you have to harm
the people you don't think you have to
have a gardener that's talks about
violence every day talk about cleaning
every day that's not the issue that
salvation you have to put money in
prevention you have to put my other sins
you know not talk about guns all the
time the children of some of the gang
members do attend his school and in the
favelas many would routinely join the
gangs when they leave but 98 percent of
all the students who have graduated from
where a have not education not violence
help them decide Stu Ramsey Sky News Rio
de Janiero